the holidays can be really difficult for
those who've lost a loved one especially
the children of our fallen service
members Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo is here meet with me now for a
lot more Laura every year the Gary
Sinise foundation hosts a special trip
that captures the spirit of Christmas
last week I joined these gold star
families Gary and the snowball Express
at Disney World for an unforgettable
five-day experience one that holds
lessons for all Americans you may have
seen this video that went viral last
week the Nashville Airport came to a
standstill when travelers paused to sing
the national anthem in the concourse
[Music]
they were honoring children of fallen
servicemen and women who were boarding a
very special flight this year as it has
for the last 13 the snowball Express
sponsored by the Gary Sinise foundation
and American Airlines has taken more
than a thousand children of the Fallen
from 87 cities on a Christmas trip
filled with joy family and remembrance
their destination was Disney every one
of these children have lost a parent and
military service we want to focus on
these kids we want to bring them
together in this healing environment and
also allow them to have a lot of fun
when they're doing it it's been really
fun and
I have liked how like we've got to go
and like all the ride that Disney World
and because this is my first time at
Disney World
[Applause]
[Music]
the walk of gratitude was just amazing
at Disney and it was super special
Stephanie Collier herself a war veteran
lost her husband to PTSD once he
returned home she and her three children
joined the snowball Express they had to
deal with a lot of young age and she was
only two months old when her father
passed so it was it was hard it's been a
huge change in them to the smiling faces
for a moment grief has been replaced
with talk of a favorite ride Alisa all
brie cheese husband died a month after
their daughter Elle was born
Melissa sees this experience as an
important one for her daughter and all
the kids here to just have fun and like
just like let go and have fun and enjoy
themselves which is really nice because
they all have quite a bird and
emotionally to bear just throughout life
and so
so I just think it's really special to
give them those moments I know holiday
is gonna be a rough time it can be
especially when someone's always missing
there is one special area at the resort
set aside to remember the absent dads
and moms who brought them together in
between the fun and all the mirth to be
had here these families take a moment
for remembrance these 650 flags
represent the men and women who have
fallen in the line of duty or when they
returned home and these families take a
moment in this room of remembrance to
one
when I walked in I was speechless it's
amazing when you look at these flags and
you realize that it represents the
parent of every child that is here and
also that this is just a small bit
because there are so many others that
have lost a family member and it's just
overwhelming you're speechless
it's very emotional my daughter did not
know her father he was the first marine
casualty after the storm post 9/11 so
she was only eight months old when he
died and just going through life without
knowing their father just hearing
stories but then becoming a part of
snowball
it makes you realize and it makes her
realize like wow there are a lot of
children here without a father and you
don't feel alone the shared experience
bonds these gold star kids and allows
them to establish close ties it's been
an awesome experience for me like over
the years I don't act like how I do now
people would make fun of me it's what
will you take with you back to Arizona
probably doing and probably just
spending a bunch of time with our family
and friends the best thing about here is
meeting new people and just making
friends they just feel like they're not
alone and it's it's children who lost
their parents and know there's so many
of them that's going through the same
thing that they're experiencing you know
at such a young age you know oh I've
made a lot friend and I just I think
it's super special that they do this for
us and I am loving here every year we
come we just make new more and more
friends as we come it's beautiful these
two girls met at the airport in
California and stuck together for the
entire five days I just saw her she's my
age I hear she was filling something
else she was doing college apps and I
was like she's a senior like waiting for
us as mom's it gives us an opportunity
to bond and then to talk about what
we're doing to help our child to grieve
and
it's a really good support system for us
as well this year I met a new family
it's their first year and she didn't
know much about things that will help
her you know through through her grief
and um I helped her through this whole
time she's been with us this whole time
and her daughter and she told me she
told me that her daughter really had
been talked about what has happened with
her father with any other children so to
come here and like watch them holding
hands and go through the park together
um that's the stuff that you really
nobody else on the outside really gets
to see you know they see kids who love
to death they don't see what they're
feeling
it's a family that sees you know they
know what we're all going through no
matter what it is you know being in a
military life is hard and then losing
somebody and it is very hard every
snowball Express ends with a special
concert by Gary Sinise and his
lieutenant dan band this year was no
exception
[Applause]
[Music]
Sinise and the band have been playing
for snowball Express families since 2007
eventually taking the entire program
under the wing of this foundation
[Music]
what do you think as you watch these
families recreative and forgetting about
their loss for a little bit and finding
that camaraderie with one another it's
wonderful to see him smile you know
that's that's the whole thing for me is
just to make these kids happy so you let
them know they're loved and appreciate
it they get a lot of love a lot of
support and it's emotional for them too
because they're all thinking about the
reason that they're here that's why we
do it in December you know it is a tough
time for children that have lost a
parent
we show them that we're not forgetting
we remember we don't forget that can
that can carry them into the next year
with a new sense that that hey I'm
important I you know what I'm going
through is is appreciated it's not being
forgotten and that there are others I'm
not alone in what I'm going through
it's a beautiful event I'm so proud that
we can support it okay that's the best
thing on television tonight what a great
job on that and thank you for doing that
I had to like make up make up
well the Gary Sinise foundation really
should be congratulated for this and
this was an incredible gift to me I mean
I did not expect to hear these stories
or the witnesses see their children's
eyes and every time every time I see one
of these children in pain or spouse in
pain I think of how we're so blessed to
live in this country but and I'm also
righteously angry at people who don't
appreciate and who put on masks and
insult Marines in public or worse and
don't appreciate all the wonderful
things that families and these kids who
are carrying on these are heroes despite
the loss and it is a heavy burden they
carry it's also a reminder of the high
costs of our freedoms Laura that I think
we forget and I was surprised to learn
from Gary and the and the families there
the high number of servicemen and women
who are plagued by PTSD once they come
home and and the 20 members of our
active and veteran members of the
military commit suicide so we need to
stand with them particularly this time
of year these families god bless them
that these kids were incredible and the
Gary Sinise foundation I had was there
other other celebrities who helped him
and do events with well there may be the
members of his band but I don't see too
many others lining up and they should
they should this is where you use I mean
if I wish I could play an instrument
it's turgid I would come we're gonna go
on - no I'm not but it would be nice we
have all these Rihanna and all these
wonderful and I know they do stuff they
do charitable things so that's great and
yeah but they're just they all have such
huge followings it would be nice to see
other people maybe occasionally go and
help on this if